how concerned are you about the impacts
we're seeing in financial markets and
what they might mean for the US economy
for the bond market worldwide well I
think we should be I don't think this is
a subprime situation exactly but lets
you know remember and observe that
Breck's its first casualties aside from
the ten percent decline in a pound have
been UK property fund six of which have
been forced to close now to close the
door on withdrawals and it's reminiscent
of barristers subprime funds before the
lemon debacle you know the property fund
sector in the UK total is about 25
billion about twenty-five percent of
which are now closed and so you know
this is an indication of illiquidity in
the system you know central banks would
counter and say all equality that you
want but the system basically it doesn't
allow liquidity flow into the proper
places and certainly here in terms of
these property funds if if they're just
one indication and you know perhaps
they'll be others to follow I think it's
something to worry about well do you
worry about it in a sense of Lehman like
counterparty problems going forward or
is this largely just a concern by people
about media reports that their property
prices are going to be worth less yeah I
think primarily the latter you know I
wouldn't go as far as a counter parties
in layman we know that you know the
structure substantially different than
it was in 2008 2009 and the banks and
counterparties are you know better
capitalized okay I don't go that far but
I do suggest it yes in in property funds
in the UK and actually in mutual funds
in the United States that they're
treated you know basically is money
market funds that individuals look at
them as something that they can have
their money the next day well in this
particular case and certainly it you
know it's obvious that if a property
can't be sold you know with within a one
two or a three day time frame and if
funds don't have enough cash than they
have liquidity problems I I don't think
that's the same situation with mutual
funds but there are indications and
situations who are high yield funds or
private equity funds where investors
treat them as
you know sort of like an ATM I think we
should be careful and I think regulators
should be looking at those types of
situations